[Musique]
nous y sommes arrivés
aidez-moi à surmonter mes sentiments voyez nous sommes maintenant
Road Animal Hospital
[Musique]
eh bien
ne regardez pas de plus
descendez du train
[Musique]
Oh
mémoire
juste
pour moi
la société
voit
[Musique]
je te vois
un autre pic clé avec nous s'ouvre à toi
soupçonne que tu m'as asservi bébé
Knopfler
miji drivable
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
muscle
rit je  m tu as le ciel
[Musique]
Peter
water
[Musique]
sousou
prend
besoin d'un peu d'eau
[Musique]
voler
très
ici tant pis
un jour bébé où l'
eau douce
[Musique]
oh salut
détruire
[Musique]
si je ne  je n'aurai pas d'eau bientôt
Oh
[Musique]
elle a été autour de
bébé
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dirait
une fois que c'était
décroché
[Musique]
tu sais ce que zéro
Stephen a
un jour
porté
voir l'homme
un jour
[Musique]
[Musique  ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
Thomas monte Taniya pour que Saul voit Molly
chez Eric - fils ils ne veulent pas d'un
médiateur mr.  Clymer a déclaré wha ouais je
veux dire j'avais l'habitude de jouer avec un cochon mais aussi
des médiators très chemi ghetto
mais c'est comme si c'était comme si une synthèse
était distillée efférente il faut juste
essayer je veux dire lentement juste fait évoluer l'
image parce que l'univers ne
vivra pas encore Ahmed  donc c'est votre
doigté comme jouer de toutes sortes de façons Je
suppose que vous en avez beaucoup entendu parler si vous perdez l'
homme ne soyez pas roi
ouais écoutez ici et là quelques
endroits sur le garçon qui joue en jouant
Willie McTell viens atterrir Willie McTell
blake aveugle  à Guam est sûr d'
eux-mêmes ainsi qu'une mère la
mère est Joe Massino mais je ne me suis jamais
réellement assis avec le dossier que vous
savez et une sorte de massage américain
maman enduite de PDCA est notre elle sur ça a
toujours été une chose proche tu sais  et vous
venez de jeter un coup d'œil à votre film à la porte, salut à
tous, dites que je vous copie pas sur le
style, c'est comme une copie suffisante pour savoir que c'est
plus juste une absorption naturelle et une
synthèse de différentes choses vraiment
c'est un Afghanistan  ouais qu'est-ce que c'est euh
quelle est ta maison sur le campus Yamaha
Stacy a fait beaucoup en Europe non nous aimons sur
mon ouais elle dit que sissy reste Bakou
Johnny fiancée famille cachée
science allemande traditionnelle makhani connecté sur
une société Jet Set Aloha - aujourd'hui ils
fument - pas de poisson sur le pays
Brûleur Metra Olivia Papa Papa Celestin mais
c'est automatique Je ne sais pas si tu pourrais faire un
circuit pour moi
l'adversaire des drapeaux
nous
traversons la ligne
pour regarder alors maintenant
le délice de la pâtisserie
[Musique]
cloche de l'église propre
essayant d'obtenir une foule même vu personne ne se
soucie de dépendre
des carillons qui jouent
ils sont tous dans le cerveau de la station
[Musique] la
congrégation scatting plus sombre
[  Musique]
un vieux soldat
nous lui avons donné une affaire frite
[Musique]
horrifié
[Musique] des
coups de feu sonnent des pierres qui claquent des portes
sont le temps que
j'ai fait une pierre
[Musique]
il y a de l'espoir plus tard je ne me souviens pas
Lucky Stars gala juste encore pour continuer
laissez-vous lire sur une
saison swing thinkin
[Musique]
Je joue sur
[Musique  ]
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
peut-être disait bonsoir avec les
Sultans of Swing merci
[Musique]
donc des
trucs dans ta maison
[Musique]
Lana souffle Dixie
décide ce que tu ne vois pas trop
[Musique]
venir dans d'autres
KATUSA
jamais le saloon
vérifier
quand
[Musique]
plutôt moi
je chanterai
[Musique]
il s'est plaint de la
pauvre âme
nous ne savons pas vraiment
ce que
le Sultan
[Musique]
essaie
l'heure
[Musique] la
plupart du temps
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]